how are you I'm fantastic I'm so happy
to be here yeah we're happy to have you
you look beautiful tonight thank you I
have to ask you something first of all
you've had a very strange experience in
that you got famous very young uh and
through the high school uh musical uh
movies huge with young teenage kids who
just when they see you shriek and scream
so what has your life been like what's
it like for you you go someplace and and
kids just start screaming I mean I
definitely lost a little bit of my
hearing right U but I think it be a
weird position for you to be in because
you don't know how do I you know people
see me and sometimes they're happy and
sometimes like but but they're they
don't start screaming you know what I'm
saying you you never really know what to
expect sometimes kids like see you and
they like just go silent and they don't
say anything other times they start
crying hysterically and it's like uh you
don't have to do that it's okay and
other times like they follow me around
and I turn around they're hiding behind
a tree or they're hiding in the bushes
and I don't know creep when're doing
that bad yeah sometimes they follow me
for years uh hopefully not they write me
letters hopefully as well I don't know
but you've uh you know just trying to
keep your life as normal as possible I
understand you're very you're very close
with your family I am I love my family
I'm actually taking my mom to Vegas for
the very first time this weekend which
I'm very excited about wait a minute
you're taking your mom to Vegas it's our
first trip to Vegas yeah that's not I
mean I would not take my mom to veg I
know no it's really funny though cuz my
mom's 50 now and she was actually going
to be a nun before she met my father so
drinking is kind of like a newf found
thing for her as soon as I turned 21 she
was like well I guess I should have a
glass of wine as well and um she kind of
loves it my mom's kind of a little party
animal wait a minute let's talk about
this not sure your mom wants you to talk
about this but so your mom uh really
didn't have alcohol at all and now she
really loves it she doesn't really love
it that's kind of what you
implied my mom just can't get B enough
uh so um she's are do you guys ever
party together we have honestly um we we
had like a not crazyer but we had a a
mother daughter night and it was like a
few of my mom's friends and they brought
their kids along at the Saddle Ranch and
um we ate some dinner we had a few
drinks and then we decided to take it to
the dance floor and um it was actually a
surprisingly good dance floor and there
were like go- go dancers and my mom's
like Oh my goodness this is so crazy I
look up and there's goo danc and they
turn around there's this guy dancing
behind me he's dancing all upon me and I
was like oh God there's a guy dancing up
on your
moming I know I know my mom's who dances
like
this that may have been me that's my
move on the floor if you're a lady and
and you see me coming at
you that is my that is my trademark I
call it the
octopus that is so C did but she's
enjoying herself yeah she totally is
it's fun it's fun to be able to have
that bonding time with my mom I love her